hey everybody I'm Tiffany Smith and
right now we are here at the TCL Chinese
Theatre and I'm talking with Fandango
frontrunners host Dave Karger it's award
season so let's talk about some of the
movies that you're really excited about
well the first one is the one that I
think is most of your fangirl alley
which is interstellar the latest movie
from Christopher Nolan who directed
inception all the Batman movies it's
such a great sci-fi epic with real
emotion - so I think much in the way
that gravity got a lot of nominations
last year I think this one could as well
another one I think that you're excited
for it's an imitation game because it
stars Benedict Cumberbatch of course
everybody loves yeah and this is a movie
where he plays Alan Turing the real-life
code breaker in England from World War
two and it really delves into all of the
challenges that he went through in his
life the film is great and Benedict's
performance is another I love Matthew
Goode as well I feel like he's an actor
that gets a little bit underrated and he
has a great role in that film as well
he's excellent in it and then as far as
benefits is concerned one of his main
competitors in the Best Actor race is
going to be Michael Keaton for Birdman a
movie you and I have both seen and
that's a film that also was gonna get
nominations across the board I think
Edward Norton Emma Stone the director
Alejandro G and Yara - should get
nominated and the movie as well such a
cool kind of behind the scenes of the
entertainment industry film well and so
kind of spot on where you're talking
about an actor who played a superhero at
one point with Michael Keaton and then
also ed Norton as well because he played
hope I know it's a very delicious kind
of coincidence there it adds a nice
little layer to the movie for sure on
the opposite extreme
as far as budgets our concern is boyhood
the Richard Linklater film that came out
this song which we know is like your
favorite of the summer which we learned
it's a great film that spans over a
decade you just really delve into these
wonderful characters so that's so that's
one to look out for I'm also very
curious about unbroken which is the
movie that Angelina Jolie directed based
on the very popular book by Laura
Hillenbrand and this is a huge world war
2 epic inspirational story definitely
seems to have the scope I've seen about
15 minutes of
and it looks very there's a lot of young
male actors in this one that I think you
should keep your eye on like Garrett
Hedlund even Jai Courtney yes jack
oconnell is the main actor who's being
talked about as a possible Best Actor
candidate as well also for Best Actor
Eddie Redmayne one of our frontrunner
guests for the theory of everything
where he plays Stephen Hawking the
brilliant physicist and a great role in
a risky role because Stephen Hawking of
course has ALS and to watch Eddie
Redmayne take this character throughout
all these decades of his life including
where he's not able-bodied anymore is
very very riveting to see I've heard
that it's just one of the best love
stories it's been on film as well it's a
beautiful story a much darker story is
Foxcatcher another true story of these
two Olympic wrestlers who develop a very
uneasy friendship with a very rich scion
of the DuPont family and that man is
played by Steve Carell Oh crazy almost
unrecognizable a very dark movie a dark
performance by Steve Carell but I think
Steve Carell and Mark Ruffalo will both
be nominated Channing Tatum is also in
the conversation but Best Actor is such
a crowded field this year that he might
get squeezed out which would be a shame
I think when you look at that movie to
its actors that are really stepping out
of the box for all of them all three of
those leads you're like these are new
roles for them I think this is very much
gonna change the trajectory of Channing
Tatum's career particularly even if he
doesn't get nominated people are gonna
look at him very differently yeah from
earlier this year I think the Oscar
voters are gonna remember the grand
Budapest hotel the great funny Wes
Anderson film with such a charming
performance by ray Fiennes and a great
cast all around such cool visuals as Wes
Anderson's movies always have and then
I'm gonna end with two smaller films
that people should be really looking out
for one is called Wilde which is the
true story of this woman named Cheryl
Strayed who decided to hike the entire
Pacific coast of the United States Reese
Witherspoon plays her in an absolutely
beautiful performance as one of my
favorite films of the year she's a
definite Best Actress nominee and then
there's a great movie called whiplash
that a lot of people are talking about
Italy an indie film darling oh yes miles
teller plays this really wonderful jazz
drummer who has a very complicated
relationship with his music teacher
played by JK Simmons who is the
frontrunner to
in Best Supporting Actor at the Oscars
and the Golden Globes I think he will be
a fixture throughout the award season I
think it's really miles tellers story
but then with this really rich juicy
mean supporting character in there as
well it's an incredible performance by
JK Simmons well I'm excited to see all
of your frontrunner interviews because
you're talking to some of those huge
actors throughout the process up until
awards season yes so it's such a fun
show to put together and I'm excited for
people to see it yeah well everybody
make sure you guys check out fandango's
frontrunners with Dave Karger I'm gonna
go run out and see all those movies
right now so I'm prepared for the next
time we chat